on the 13th of october 1989
the town of danner wisconsin was shaken
by a seismic event
unlike anything they'd ever experienced
this might have been written off as an
earthquake where not for one disturbing
factor
the ground shaking event was accompanied
by a huge spike of radioactivity
with the strange phenomenon happening a
month before the berlin wall was torn
down
during a period of the cold war that
historians call the year of crisis
it's easy to understand why the people
of danner immediately assumed the worst
but the huge eruption they felt wasn't
the result of a nuclear bomb going off
the scp foundation was alerted to the
event in danner when they picked up a
series of radio transmissions coming
from just outside the town
when they arrived they found something
incredible
like something out of a sci-fi movie
standing at the quake's epicenter
was a creature that looked to be from
another world
standing two meters tall and weighing
almost 300 kilograms
the being was green and brown in color
with a bulky humanoid body
its head was a different story though
and resembled a gigantic house fly with
a proboscis
and huge stereoscopic eyes surprisingly
the strange creature did not immediately
go on a rampage
instead the being designated scp-2273
appeared to be exhausted injured and
extremely malnourished
it offered no resistance at all to the
foundation containment team
and it was taken to site 17 without
conflict
while the scp foundation is no stranger
to visitors from other worlds
there was something especially unusual
about this supposed alien invader
the doctors who examined the creature
and treated its injuries found an
appendage that seemed to function as an
organic radio transmitter
and large open wounds on its shoulder
blades and forearms where further
appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern
the creature's upper arms and torso were
dotted with a variety of scars and
markings that
on closer inspection looked like
military badges was this some kind of
wounded intergalactic soldier who had
been stranded on earth
if it was then how were the organic
badges on this alien's exoskeleton a
near-perfect match to military badges
worn by soldiers in the soviet union
even if they did reference a unit that
didn't officially exist within the
soviet army
the scientists were sure this alien
wasn't an
alien at all underneath its exoskeleton
was a non-anomalous human being if that
was true
then this was even more terrifying than
an extraterrestrial visitor
the scientists were sure that the ussr
had developed a new kind of organic
armor
and this anomaly showing up in wisconsin
was the result of a test on u.s
soil that had gone wrong if that was the
case
then there was no telling how many more
of these exoskeletons were out there
and would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly
and find out more while scp-2273 was
recovering
they called in dr friedrich an on-site
psychologist who could speak several
languages including russian
dr friedrich would be tasked with
interrogating the scp on his origins and
the nature of the suit
the interview was conducted via am radio
from a separate observation chamber
as the biological transmitter seemed to
be scp-2273's only method of
communication
the interview began with dr friedrich
speaking to scp-2273 in russian
only for 2273 to respond that dr
friedrich's accent was atrocious
and requesting he used german instead
scp-2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
major alexei belatrov
initially resisted being interviewed he
believed that he was a prisoner of war
being held by the american military
according to him he had been
in the middle of battle and that the
americans had killed his men and left
him for dead in the wilderness
nothing that dr friedrich told him that
there was no war
or that the foundation was not
affiliated with the u.s government
could convince him otherwise and he
refused to talk further
before a second interview was conducted
bellatrov was given an old copy of the
level 1 researcher general debrief
as a way of helping him further
understand the nature of the foundation
and his containment belatrov was more
cooperative after that
though the realization that he would
most likely be kept in containment for
the rest of his life caused him great
distress
and he was unwilling to speak to dr
friedrich for another three days
dr friedrich didn't give up though and
when bellatra finally opened up to the
doctor
he began to tell him more and more
bellatroph told the doctor that when he
was a child
russia was hit by an american nuclear
warhead and that the soviet union
immediately retaliated the resulting
nuclear conflict
which belatrov called the war to end the
world caused
massive devastation and left most of the
planet dangerously irradiated
that is why he had the exoskeleton it
was to shield him from the radiation and
allow him to survive
above ground unfortunately bellatrov
knew
very little about how the suit was made
or how it worked
saying that it was built by the
engineers and that it grew
naturally over a period of several years
but belatrov hadn't made the decision
himself
it was his parents who had volunteered
him as a test subject for the
exoskeleton suit program when he was
still young
hoping it would give him a better chance
at survival the process of bonding the
exoskeleton to the human body was
extremely painful
but according to balotrov its advantages
far outweighed the pain
the suit not only helped him survive in
a nuclear wasteland
but made him a better soldier the suit
allowed him to lift and carry up to 1200
kilograms
gave him stereoscopic vision and the
organic radio transmitter allowed him to
communicate with other soldiers across
long distances as well as listen in on
encrypted enemy transmissions
the wounds on his shoulders and arms
where it looked like appendages had been
ripped out
were where his weapons and supply packs
had previously been mounted
bellatrov had been stationed with his
men in the area he was discovered when
they were attacked by american soldiers
the soldiers had ripped off bellatrop's
weapons and supply pack and did the same
to all his men
as well they were all shot with
bellatroph being spared for the moment
only because the americans had
identified him as the commanding officer
suddenly there was a bright flash of
light and the american soldiers
vanished not only that but the landscape
changed
where there had been a post-nuclear
wasteland before now there were lush
green trees
injured and disoriented bellatrov began
sending distress signals
only to have those signals intercepted
by the scp
foundation the most interesting part of
belatrov's story
as far as the foundation was concerned
came during his fourth interview
when dr friedrich asked him about the
engineers who had designed the
suit in beltrav's own words they weren't
truly known to man
until the years of the great war and the
revolution the french found them
in buried cities where the western
allies were digging their trenches
eventually they were made to build
weapons for the war by both sides
by his description these engineers
didn't sound
human but they were by no means unknown
to the scp
foundation belatrov described the
engineers as humanoid
nocturnal covered in fur and possessing
technology and intelligence far beyond
that of any human
those familiar with the foundation's
history might already know the engineers
by their foundation designation
of scp-1000 or their more commonly known
name
bigfoot a quick rundown scp-1000 are a
species of intelligent humanoid primates
that lived alongside humanity in highly
advanced cities until their own
technology was turned against them
not only were their cities wiped off the
face of the earth but
70 percent of their population was
slaughtered and the survivors were
driven mad to the point that their
mental faculties were no higher than
those of a chimpanzee
or gorilla the scp foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from human
contact
in fear of what the creatures would be
able to do to humanity
if they ever regained their memories and
full mental function
and rumors have been spread about them
possessing deadly anomalous
properties but evidently the destruction
of the scp-1000 species never occurred
in bellatrop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as
complete in that timeline
humanity regained contact with scp-1000
after discovering their underground
cities sometime during world war one
after this discovery both allied and
access powers began recruiting them to
build weapons
and their weapons played a role in both
the russian revolution
and the second world war it was because
of these technological advantages that
the cold war escalated into what would
become the war to end all
wars both sides were armed with not only
nuclear warheads
but highly advanced radiation-proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue
even after the total destruction of the
planet while the humans fought above
ground
life continued as normal for scp-1000 in
their underground
cities as veletrov noted they never wore
the armor themselves
as they had no need to venture above
ground only soldiers wear
armor and this is not their war
bellatroph continued to adjust to life
in containment and
sitting for regular interviews with dr
friedrich he was given the rations
provided for humanoid anomalies but in
much larger quantities
as the suit required him to eat around 8
000 calories a day to keep it
functioning
bellatrov also began taking advantage of
his ability to access the foundation's
library he would often read or listen to
classical music
particularly by the russian composer
tchaikovsky
he seemed especially fond of reading the
time machine by h.g
wells no surprise given he was able to
directly relate to the
experience of living through an
apocalypse and being transported to a
strange timeline
with no way to return home but with
little else to occupy his time
bellatrov began to displace symptoms
consistent with post-traumatic stress
disorder
reporting in his now regular interviews
with dr friedrich that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought
and the lives he had taken in combat the
suit was making the problems worse too
it seemed
it was as if he could never forget as
one of its features was an ability to
store
and replay memories this feature was
intended as a strategic aid that would
allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat
this only served to force bellatrov into
reliving his most painful memories
again and again every night as he tried
to sleep
you would see the faces of his men their
weapons torn from their exoskeletons
laying in the dirt
after being gunned down by the enemy
like many veterans
bellatrov was being hit all at once with
the harsh realities of war
now that his brain wasn't solely focused
on keeping him alive
it had time to process all the horrors
he'd experienced
he told dr friedrich i trained alongside
these men for years
before they put us back on the surface
since we were all young children
we were brothers and i gave them the
order to surrender
and got them killed i should have died
with them
while the story of scp-2273 ends here
the story of alexi belatrov scp-2273-1
continues in 2018 belatrov was allowed
passage to volgrad russia
as part of an anomaly reintegration
program while he was unable to secure
employment within the russian government
as he had hoped
he eventually was taken in by a
monastery and continued to write letters
to dr friedrich
until friedrich's eventual death from
lymphoma-related complications
there's plenty more on the monastery the
anomaly reintegration program
and what happened to major bellatrov
when he returned to russia
but that will have to be a story for
another day but if you're hungry for
more scp content right now
go check out our series on scp-5000 the
suit
or the two-part saga of what happened at
site 13.
goodbye for now my friends